قد يكون هذا هو مستقبل العلاج بالتدليك،
روبوت يُدعى إيما إيما يرمز إلى
خبير أتمتة التدليك المتلاعب،
الدكتور برنت باور هو جزء من فريق في Mayo
Clinic يدرس هذا الجهاز الذي يستخدم
شكلاً من أشكال التدليك العلاجي يسمى توينا
لاستهداف آلام أسفل الظهر غير المحددة.
هذا في الواقع جهاز يمكنه
اكتشاف نقاط الوخز بالإبر ومن
ثم تقديم العلاج المستهدف. يقول باور إنه
لا يوجد حاليًا عدد كافٍ من
المعالجين بالتدليك لتلبية الطلب. قد تكون إيما
قادرة على المساعدة في بعض عبء العمل الذي تم
تصميمه بحيث يكون لديه ذكاء اصطناعي
يمكن تعلمه  في كل مرة يعمل فيها مع
نفس المريض، يمكنه تحديد
نقاط مختلفة من التوتر العضلي، ومن
ثم من خلال خوارزميات تتجاوز بكثير
فهمي، يمكنه في الواقع
استهداف الآلة للانتقال من نقطة إلى أخرى إلى
أعماق مختلفة، كما يقول باور،
ويمكن للجهاز أيضًا استخدام تدليك مختلف.  وتنتقل
التقنيات باستخدام الأدوات التي يمكن ربطها
بالذراع من
حركة فرك إلى حركة قرص وأكثر من ذلك، لكنه
يقول إنها لن تحل محل
المعالجين بالتدليك إذا تم إعداد الأمور مع
معالج إذا كانت الآلة قادرة على القيام بالكثير
من الرفع الثقيل  ومن ثم
يمكن للمعالج وضع اللمسات الأخيرة والتأكد من
تغطية الأمور. أعتقد أنه يمكننا
حماية المعالج لدينا والسماح له برؤية
المزيد من المرضى ولكن مع قدر أقل من الاهتمام
والرعاية لمدة نصف دقيقة، أنا آندي جايثر